hello everyone and welcome to round two
of the 2019 isle of man chess tournament
it's well this that's a more fee here
from the previous video but it's a 19
year old Russian Grand Master Alexei
Serrano vs world champion Magnus Carlsen
it's a really an interesting game and
really a hard game so I do hope you
enjoy it without further ado let's check
it out
Tirana witted the white pieces opens
with E 4 and we will have again a test
of Furcal since World Chess Championship
preparation we have c5 across and the
Sicilian defenses on the board
Knight f3 Knight to c6 and now d4 just
going after the center to go for some
rapid development C captures on d4
Knight captures and the knight to f6
we have Knight to c3 and c5 now a
Carlsen of course going for his first
league of B'nai deep to b5 and b6 with
Bishop to g5 by cerana and now a6 giving
away the night a3 we have Knight 2 a 3
and now b5 the last / Pelican variation
with Bishop captures an f6 G captures on
f6 and now Knight to d5 and excellent
outpost for the night this has been
thoroughly analyzed and played many
times before so nothing new here Bishop
to g7 by Carlson and now Bishop to d3
developing preparing to castle cross and
offers a trade of knights with 97 he
wants to get rid of White's stronger
knight on d4 d5 Knight captures Queen
captures and now c4 and here cousin goes
f5 it's not again a new move over 200
games in the database with this exact
same setup in in big tournaments we have
castles by both sides with castles by
surrounded castles by cousin and now
Queen to h5 bringing the Queen into the
attack there is no actual danger of
capturing here because black can just
always push efore and lock down that
light square bishop but still it's a
very active position for white so here
there are a couple moves that are very
popular like rook to b8 like capturing
on c4 across and chooses a move that has
been played only five times before and
it is probably something he had prepared
for the
a championship against Fabiano Caruana
as up until this point neither of them
spent any time basically
so d5 you always know what we say about
the Sicilian in d5 if you can play it
you should play it and here Carlsen can
definitely play it so we have C captures
on d5 and now Queen to d8 asking white
what do you want to do I'm preparing to
push f4 so here why it has the capture
on f5 it's not a not a pleasant move
it's a very ugly looking move you know
breaking up your your pawns in the
center allowing Queen captures on d5 but
what else is there if you play something
like f3 then cross and we'll play f4 and
now it's black we'll be attacking now
crossing doing walking to h8 this Bishop
is basically a pawn now he will go rook
to g8 and it will be well once the
bishop is developed you didn't get the
arrow broke over to see a will be a just
a very pleasant position for black so it
captures on f5 by cerana this is in both
of their sprepper both of their
preparation Queen captures on d5 and now
there is one game in the database that
reached this exact same position from
2019 also our entire versus even any
Verrocchio's where Quinta e 2 was played
and black was able to win that game but
here we have rook a to d1 it is a new
move so as I move into 18 we have a
completely new game this doesn't catch
cross and by surprise he just continues
in pretty quickly
fashion he plays d4 allowing this
discovery but it's only a pawn so
special characters and b5 offering well
not offering but attacking the Queen and
now Queen captures on f5 so here
everything gets traded down Queen
captures Bishop captures and the now
Bishop to d7
attacking the bishop either forcing it's
due to a passive square like rush up to
g6 or offering a trade that whereas that
white will get the activity 7 square for
his rook so here concentrate with Bishop
captures rook captures and now Bishop
captures and b2
attacking the knight Knights the c4 and
Bishop to g7 and white goes g3 here you
could go rook a to d1 double up along
the D file but the white might have some
background weaknesses so instead g3
first
and as white allotted caution will now
not allow white the double rooks under
under D foul
well white will double rocks and the D
file but it will not be exposed as just
doubling immediately instead of playing
g3 first so here if you look at the
position the material on the board is
equal it's a bishop against a knight
plays on both sides of the board so
bishop is to be preferred a little bit
on the other hand the cross and has
three point islands serrano has two
point island so white white is a little
bit better here so rook F to d8 offering
a trade with rook to d1 doubling up and
de now cross and trades once captures
captures and here is the I believe the
first moment in the game where Carlsen
started to think a little bit and he
played rook the c8 he wants to get the
rook into the game maybe play works you
want check bring two rogue back when the
a to pawn create a past a pawn and start
pushing it so what what can surrounded
ooh he played Knight to d6 putting
pressure on the f7 pawn and also
preparing to win the e4 pawn crossing
goes rook the c1 check as intended King
to g2 and now rook to c2 preparing III
but also just preparing to capture on a
2 also instead of rook to c2 there was
the immediate III which kind of breaks
down White's a nice bone structure on
the Kings side after F captures now rook
C to check King moves and now you
capture this guy here and now you've
messed up White's pawn structure and
you've created your own passed pawn but
Carson prefers the other line he plays
rook the c2
leaves the option of playing e3 you can
always capture here we have Knight
captures on e4 of course not allowing e3
rook captures on a2 and now rook to d8
check Carlson has to block with the
bishop in the now comes Knight to f6
check King to g7 and now Knight the h5
check King back to g8 and here serrano
could force a draw with a Knight to f6
check followed by Knight to h5 trigger
but he continues to play the game Carson
would not be able to escape it if Knight
f6 checking g7 Knight a5 checked engage
6 trying to trade it wouldn't really be
in in Black's favor because after rook
captures Knight captures you also lose
the f7 pawn and I was just a much better
position for white if I can draw this it
will be it will be our well with playing
the absolute best moves so G
for first now the idea is you want to
push h4 g5 and then the night when it
comes to f6 will be protected by the g5
phone and only then will you try to
create further threats against the black
king with a 5 by cross and constant
starts pushing his past pawn and now g5
as planned with a for further pushing
the past pawn and now h4 preparing this
knight to f6 idea that we mentioned so
what do you play here what would you
play in this position it's a really
tricky hand game so if you feel like it
how would you proceed in the same game
feel free to pause the video and well
what would you do here so for those of
you who decided that pushing the past
pawn was a good idea let's see what
happens if a3 is played then you get a
knight to f6 check as plan of King g7
and h5 preparing h6 so you have to bring
the rook into the game out to continue
pushing your passport rugby - but now
knight eh
check King has to go back and now you
get h6 so what can you do here there are
some very nasty threats here like Knight
f6 check the King is no longer able to
go to g7 you'll have to go to a chat and
then rook captures on f8 will be made
again with with the rhyme so you have to
make some room for the King f5 but now
you get to look to d7 again the idea is
the same Knight of 6 check followed by
rook captures on h7 mate you would have
to go back
rook to b6 only move and now Knight f6
check just wins the material you have to
capture it there is no other way rook
captures G captures and after Bishop
captures on h6 you will have this
endgame where Sarah is upper rook very
quickly he will win back another pawn
bringing his King into the game and it
will be just just a slow painful death
for white for black so for those of you
who decided that pushing the pawn was
the way to go sorry but it's not a cross
in place look the b2 he recognizes of
course that it's a very important tempo
you have to get the rook into the game
as soon as possible
Knights the f6 check by cerana King g7
and now h5 preparing the setup that
we've just seen but now cross and has a
rook to b5 so putting the g5 phone under
attack and again what do you play here
Serrano played f4 if you try a
six immediately then after King to g6
you will get well you can always play f4
now but now it's it's different because
of Bishop to e7 attacking the rook and
the night so the correct line is the
rook to e8 Bishop captures and now rook
the a6 if you don't want to mess up your
pawn structure you will try to recapture
with the rook but now a3 black will not
allow the roof to capture because well
the pawn is just far too advanced so you
have to play King give three kings the
h5 unpinning
and now you will have to capture it
there is no more captures with check so
if you capture with the room just to
rock a five will win you will have to
capture with the Jeep on and now after
Ruby three check in before he captures
on h6 you get this position where black
is again up a pawn so Serena doesn't go
for h6 but rather f4 it is the strongest
move and I believe up until this point
Serena was well within his preparation
maybe he's even within his preparation
here because I think pretty much every
move he played until at this point and
didn't even beyond this point was the
engine stop recommendation so with h6 by
Carlsen now not allowing the pawn
captures because of King captures on f6
so Knight the eh check is a possibility
but if you go 98 check King to g8 9 of 6
check King to g7 knife the EI check it
can be a draw for example if you go King
to h7 trying to break free doesn't work
because of g6 check captures and is now
rook to d7 check King to h8 and now each
captors and g6 threatening to win
material here so you would have to try
something rugby 6 but now f5 and it's
just just an overwhelming position for
white f6 is coming g7 is coming and
that's just it so if course and would go
something like King tha tour h7 but of
course if he keeps on repeating this
it's again a draw so it's a very
interesting moment that up until this
point serrano played the brilliant
preparation every move is a top engine
recommendation and cross and is barely
barely hanging in so it's really amazing
to put the world champion in such a
position where
unable to do anything he has to play the
absolute best move to survive every move
so Knight to g4 instead he doesn't go
for this line he's not threatening to
win dh6 pawn so how can Carson prevent
this well there is the move crossing
plate is Bishop to e3 he doesn't allow
this rook Bishop to be a target on a
fate so he plays Bishop d3 another idea
was just to give up the bishop right
away with align the rook to be to check
King f3 rook the b3 check King to e 2
and do not look to be for point is G
captures on h6 now King h7 you allow the
capturing of the Bishop rook captures on
f8 and the now rook captures on f4 92f
to getting out of the way in the now
King captures on h6 King the e3 pushing
route back rook f5 and now looked a it
going after the past one of course King
captures or look at verse and h5 and now
rook captures on a4 we will get the same
game where it's a king and rook against
our king rook and Knight and unless it's
a very specific position black will be
able to hold this to a draw so instead
Crossing goes for Bishop to e3 it's a
bit of a different line he gives out the
h2 exponent we have Knight captures on
h6 and now Bishop to e7 going for a
similar line but a bit different so
attacking the rook rook the d7 and now
Bishop captures on g5 here cross and
offers the bishop because if you capture
the bishop you get the rook captures on
g5 the knight doesn't really have a good
escape square all of the escape squares
are covered so what you can do here is
King to f3 as the white king is in check
so King to 3 and now King captures on h6
just winning back the piece and after
Luke to a7 going after the passed pawn
king captures here rook captures here
and the coffin is the one who is up upon
so not the greatest continuation with F
captors and g6 so serrano plays Knight
captures on f7 again the best
continuation and now rook to beat you
with check with King to f3 and only now
Bishop captures on f4 so Carson is very
confident that he's able to hold this so
what do you play
here again I hope you were not
considering keen captors here because
then across and has a roof to have to
check came to g5 you can capture on f7
and white cannot afford to trade because
the da pond is just much faster and a
white will not be able to reach it and
if h6 which is interesting King g8 rope
d8 check King to h7 now you will have to
go to a eight
but now rook to b7 and everything pretty
much unwinds in a draw captures now
you're going to go rook to b5 check in
to have sex and you can even capture it
as there is no made because the rook can
just walk it captures captures and it's
a draw by insufficient material so after
Bishop captures cerana
again doesn't go 14 characters he plays
Knight to e5 a discovered check from the
rook King to H sorry that's not a king
king to h6 and now King captures on f4
finally and we have a three by Carlson
look you could go rook to e7 just
putting a room behind the passport but
cerana plays rook to d5 he says okay you
know if maybe cousin captures here I'll
just make a discovery and knights the d3
I discovered check and pick up his rook
you know it's not unimaginable that this
can happen but okay rook the be four by
Carson of course the world champion is
not interested in in blundering the game
dis oh this way
King to g3 and now a to proceeding to
push the pawn we have rook to a five now
putting the row behind the passed pawn
and now a one queen cousin just gives it
away as he knows how to draw a rock
against a rook and Knight we have rook
captures on a one and now King captures
on h5 ruk a five and here it seems that
well now you have 50 moves as there are
no more points and no more captures
world will most likely happen you have
50 moves to beat black otherwise it's a
draw by a 50 move rule repetition so
Carlsen goes rook to b1 and sorry that's
a b2 a rook to B 1 and here we have King
to f4 we have looked to f1 check and
here cerana just played nice to have
three I discovered to check from the
rook and it was in this position that
they agreed to a draw
as Sauron is not interested to press it
is of course possible for black to mess
it up but sadhana whitcross and having
one hour on the clock doesn't doesn't
think that he will be able to grind down
the world champion although there were
cases for example in 1996 you did Pagar
with the white pieces played against
Garry Kasparov and Kasparov was able to
to win a game rook and Knight against
the rook and I think you did really
needed a few more moves to survive but
before reaching more 50 she had to
resign in face of certain doom I I will
find this game and attach it and put it
in the description block it will be the
first thing you will see I will put a
link to the PGN so if you're interested
in this game how Kasparov maneuvered his
pieces but yet here Serena is not
interested in checking if if course and
is able to hold this so of course they
agree to a draw and a lot of people were
saying that how come this is such a
strong variation for white how come
Khurana did not use it in the World
Chess Championship match in 2018 but the
thing is across and ran straight into
this preparation Serena threw at him
Saran applied the absolute best
preparation the absolute best moves the
top recommendations by the engines
engine basically and Carson will just
easily drew this so I I don't think
Khurana would actually gain anything by
playing this line in the world's
championship match if I don't know it
just seems that that wouldn't make any
difference because if a cross intruder
game against the top engine
recommendations here so III don't think
it would be a good idea for for Corona
to have tried this during the World
Chess Championship match i William I
just wanted to share that with you guys
this is a game that ended fairly quickly
so I decided to make a video on it right
away I would like to thank John cousin
sin-bearing Malone for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
on my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the of the
Isle of Man a grand swiss tournament and
of course checking up on your wonderful
suggestions as usual so thank you all I
will see you soon
have an excellent rest of your day